thank you councillors and uh good
afternoon everyone can you just remain
standing for the opening prayer please
father we just come before you and give
you thanks again for the privilege of
being able to deliberate on important
issues for this community and just ask
for wisdom as we work through the agenda
this afternoon we ask that in jesus name
amen
afternoon councillors and
it's good to see a full turnout this
afternoon
it's a nice warm room so
it's a good place to be
um
so we don't i'll declare the meeting
open and we don't have
any apologies
so uh are there any conflicts of
interest that counselors wish to declare
at this point in time
do not
thank you um so we need to move on to
the confirmation of
minutes and reports
and first up is the confirmation of the
minutes of the ordinary meeting of
council held on tuesday the 13th of july
somebody like to move that that be seen
as a true and correct record please
thank you councillor heisted is there a
second for that
councillor dixon thank you
are there any alterations required to
that report councillor davis thank you
just a question about the uh
time and temperature clock
it says here that we're going to replace
the clock and in the paper it said the
parkiki lines are paying for the
replacement of the clock okay so it's
so so my understanding is after the
meeting there was an offer made from
[ __ ] alliance to
to fund it is that correct
yeah that's good do we need to make an
amendment
uh that reflects the meeting um the
minutes reflect the meeting so
uh i guess that can be raised at some
point in the future but i think it's a
really uh
wonderful offer from parkiki and i just
didn't
thank them very much for for making that
offer
is there anything else from
the minutes
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say hi
against the motion that is carried
right uh
confirmation of the minutes of the
extraordinary council meeting held on
wednesday 21 july would somebody like to
move that be seen as a true and correct
record councillor reed to have a
secondary for that
counselor macdonald thank you are there
any alterations required to that report
durant i'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried is there
any
uh urgent late business that needs to be
discussed this afternoon there's not
thank you
right we move on to
item five and we have the
freedom camping bylaw
oh sorry
my apologies yes there is there is one
item of urgent general business
and it relates to the
community awards
so
if somebody was able to
move that that be considered later on in
the afternoon that would be good thank
you councillor phillips and seconded
councillor grant
all those in favor please say aye
against emotions carried and thank you
councilman for bringing that to my
attention
um
right item five freedom camping bylaw
and we have a memo from the planning
consultant i'm not sure who's going to
speak to this one so
are you the planning consultant
i'll endeavor to be your worship
so
um this is a um a wash-up
of mr keith hovel before we departed the
council
to
pose the question of whether we should
have a
freedom camping bylaw in the district
and that's really to
take stock of the fact that
while we don't have a lot of internet or
very little with any international
tourism at the moment
there's still a
strong degree of domestic tourism
and while we're not regarded as a high
freedom camping
environment
there still is in the view of of mr
hovel and i will also defer to
mrs gurken who may want to
contribute to the discussion from a
visitor point of view
there is
some freedom camping that does occur and
uh
on balance it's felt that we should have
a bylaw that at least regulates where
the uh
activity can occur as mr hovel has quite
rightly pointed out it's not like you
can have a blanket prohibition no matter
how
inclined you may feel towards moving in
that direction we do have to provide a
particular place for freedom camping to
occur
and so the bylaws seem to be the best
means by which
to regulate that activity like
happens elsewhere in the country
thank you
steve sonia before i open for
discussions or anything you wish to add
to that
um probably just to reiterate the chief
executive comments it's not a huge issue
for us but we do have a lot of freedom
you know campus beans coming through the
district so to have the bylaw is a good
safety net for council
okay councillors um
i just endorse what's already been been
said uh it hasn't been a huge issue for
us and
that is quite different to
our neighbours on the north side and uh
on the
southern side around southern district
and
in tiana area so
if a council's of a mind then this is
the time to to raise that so it's open
for discussion
councillor davis i think it would be
appropriate to still go ahead and and
produce a by-law at least then we've got
some general rules of where they can
park and what they they're entitled to
so i would be um in favor of moving this
recommendation great so you're moving it
do i have a second of that council read
thank you
okay so it's been moved and segmented is
there any other comment that counselors
would like to add to this like i think
personally
developing a bylaws gives us the tools
should and when anything arise so
i think it's
the right direction
but uh if there's nothing further i'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say i against the motions carried thank
you councillors
right we'll move on then to
the matara community board
board meeting in the minutes
and we have a set of minutes here from
the 5th of july that need to be received
um and
there are any recommendations contained
within them to be be ratified so they
are
open for discussion at this point do you
want to make any comment before we open
that up stupid okay
so i will note that we do have the chair
of the community board
and presents this afternoon and welcome
ellen it's good to have you have you
here
uh okay so open for any discussion
counsellors
if there's no discussion with somebody
like to move it oh i've got some
questions okay great
through your worship
just a question because i'm a little bit
confused reading the minutes as to
whether or not
the um
building
the the relocation of the building is
actually going to happen
so can you confirm whether it's going to
happen
actually going on
okay
so uh i'm going to
defer to councillor phillips in the
initial stages do you would you like to
make some comment neville thank you
worship um
eleanor will intervene here if i um miss
anything but uh in reading the minutes
what what happened was that the
discussion by the board
that um first of all
we're going to seek a
feasibility study and also
whether or not
the project
is warranted in matera because
following our
meeting in the town meeting there was
one or two
people that were
not
overly happy with the project
but hasn't stopped us moving forward and
the reason why we want to go ahead with
the feasibility study and also the
timeline proposals and relocation of the
material railway station
is
to get
whether or not it's viable like at the
end of the day
why are we going to spend all this money
if
if for arguments like that it's not
going to be viable project
and
i'd much rather spend the 30 000 now
than have a burden of lots of money
spend on on it
the board is um
committed to buying the section
uh for its relocation um
and that is the go ahead
so
if
the
all the dots are lined up
at least the land is purchased and ready
to be shifted
okay so look thank you uh neville and
from
what you're saying and looking at the
recommendation my understanding is that
you need confirmation that
what the direction you're going in is
the right one and you're asking council
to
commission some conceptual architectural
plans and a feasibility study to
just to look at what the reality is as
opposed to
some of the ideas that have been
reasonably loose
to this point in time correct and the
board the board is willing to withdraw
pay for that that to go ahead because at
the end of the day
uh it needs it needs certainty before it
commits itself completely
are you grants with that all
yeah
okay thank you um
so while we're on this subject and
before there's any other questions ellen
do you want to make any comment at this
point in time you're welcome to to make
comet as cheers
was very um to saying well no um
um
okay thank you
so uh council grant then councillor
dixon
thank you worship it's just a it's just
a shame it's going to cost thirty
thousand dollars
to come out of your material
beautification fund just to get a report
and say no it's not viable
there's no other way of
even fifteen ten thousand dollars okay i
could probably look at that but thirty
thousand dollars
that's a shame yeah i know you've got to
cross your t's and dot your eyes and do
the whole lot but
it's a lot of money
but that's that's that's it's the
material beautification fund if that's
what that's what the community
board has gone for that's you know
yeah and and i guess the role of the
community board is to to manage what
they see is in the best instance of the
community um glennis
thank you worship
i understand that nobody actually owns
the railway station this year there's a
lot there is a dollar some but it hasn't
been
uh kiwi rail on the railway station
at the moment so should we be doing a
study before they give authority
to
pass ownership
do you want to make a comment yesterday
yeah thank you worship um
yes councillor dixon the um
agreement has been reached with kiwi
brow to uh purchase the building for the
sum of one dollar but that agreement is
conditional upon the council having
obtained all aboard a resource consent
a building consent and funding to enable
enable the building to be eradicated
so the agreement is just conditional it
hasn't been fulfilled
and the timeline has lapsed
but as there's no queue of other
prospective purchases lined up
i don't believe it's a problem in
reconstructing
an extended agreement for that but we
still have to go through due diligence
or
uh the council board abandons the
project i guess this particular
recommendation in front of you is saying
you want to spend a bit of money
to ascertain whether it is actually
feasible
and that no doubt feasibility will look
at
issues around
the
physical condition of the building
the
allowances made for its relocation and
restoration
um
and obviously the end use the board
wants to put it to
and then it will come back to the
board and the council to determine
whether yes it is a viable option or no
it's not but in the wings sits key rail
that as far as i'm aware are still keen
to see the community take the building
over and bring it back to its former
glory
thank you
councilman did you
have something you want to make
i went and looked at the railway station
yesterday and walked around it and
it is in a very dilapidated state the
roof where the iron is is completely
rusty and have to be totally replaced
the west wall is virtually rotted
probably 80 of it is rotted weatherboard
and the south wall so it's in a very
very poor state but
and i would be
low to spend 30 000
because i think it's a project that's
going to cost a fortune to move it
somewhere
so
that's my view on it anyway
okay so um is there any other counselors
want to make any comment on this one i
guess from councillor reed
thank you your worship i think it's down
to the material community board and the
people of matera to make that decision
and then come back to us with what
they've decided
regardless of cost i think they're
prepared to put the money up
who are we to say yay or no
yeah i guess my my thoughts will be very
much akin to that
we've got a community board they've been
duly elected
from the people of matara they've got a
sum of funds that they are responsible
for expending
and they are more connected to the
community than than the councillors i
understand that the
question is is not in a good state um
but there are some options for the
future so
i think
it's important that
they before they make a final decision
about whether this is the right thing to
do actually understand the full
ramifications of what an end result will
look like and probably more importantly
what facility will it end up providing
to the community and what will it
cost so yes i agree with councillor
grant that thirty thousand dollars
is a lot
um but it might be easier to spend that
money now than find yourself
down a hole for a whole lot more
when you've got a relocated
shell
okay so is there any further comment
with councillor heisted
you thank you i just have a question
around have any of the funding partners
been approached to assist with
feasibility studies often that is
an option um
i know it is occurring elsewhere so i
just wonder if the community board has
turned his mind to a funding partner
you're one of the funding partners
assisting with that i don't know
that's occurred i know the community
board will have talked to various
funding potential funding partners about
the whole
project but whether it's been
narrowed down to a concept i don't know
neville do you want to make any comment
to that
thank you worship not at the stage you
worship
we have had primary talks with
cost and
juanita about uh financial
assistance for the future but not as not
as a concept to get the plans sort of
sorted or anything like that
i'd just like to say that
you know the decision was not taken
lightly by the board about spending
thirty thousand dollars after all it is
uh the local money out of from the local
ratepayer
and
at the end of the day
you
have to be certain that you're doing the
right thing
and to me 30 000 spent will give you the
right answer
and uh i think the board then can walk
away either really pleased that it's
going to go ahead or that it's done 110
effort to try and save the railway
station
okay um any other comment from
councillor davis
through your worship um
do you
maybe i'll put this one to neville
with with the feasibility study what
exactly is the ball going to get like
what detail are you going to get
as much as we can for the money we're
going to spend but the detail that we
want is basically just concept plans
about what it may look like shifted to
queens park
and what the future in my home for it
and and
sorry no no
i would imagine that a visa feasibility
study would look very much at the
the balance of cost against value
obtained from
resurrecting the railway station
somewhere other than it is now
that's true and part of the discussion
was that if it wasn't viable for matera
then it may be viable for somewhere else
yeah and that was the discussion that
that
whatever we spend that the money may be
spent within the district somewhere if
if you understand what i mean like it
may not be viable to be left in matera
but it may be viable to go somewhere
else
parts of
for argument's sake not the whole
but it's it could be money well spent
as far as i'm concerned look uh
the decision is the communities it's not
it's the community border trying its
utmost to be able to save the building
like at the end of the day if it doesn't
doesn't
save the building
then it's done 10-10 to try and save it
there
and that's what the aspect is for the
community board and myself
okay any other further comments with
regard to that one item is there any
other items on the that set of minutes
that
need discussion counselor heisted
yes thank you just a clarification on
point two there's a recommendation the
council contribute eleven thousand
towards a mold to be used across the
district is that is the intention of the
board there in addition to the 8 000
already or increasing it to 11.
now that's the uh
the
8000 is not included in the 11 000.
so that will be the the cost of the mole
additional help
what is the mold
why is it a mole no what is it what is
the mold is the mold the the the molar
pressure
sign
yes the outside
yeah so the mole could be used within
the district if it so i wish to be
so the mole could be used in any part of
the town or any part of the district
so my understanding just from the rough
outline i've had is that
there is the community board are very
keen to go ahead with
the particular design they've settled on
and they think that you know with very
little
variation it might be in time something
that could be utilized in other parts of
the district
and
it would be good to get that done at
this point in time but that's
this is very ellen do you want to make
any comment on that one
um
right
and
yeah okay um
any other comment oh counselor phillips
thank you worship i i just want to
comment about uh item number four the
removal of the blue gum trees in
henderson park
um on
while it doesn't stay there
in the minutes i'm highly disappointed
exactly what's been left it's it's a bit
of a mess
and
i'd like the council to
formally write a report to the board
in regards to why it was left like that
to me it's in a
health and safety state
and that
that some of the trees that were left
can be blown over and if there's any
children walking around or playing in
that area which they do
i think it's a bit of a hazard and
to me
leaving
a sight like that in the middle of your
town
is
unacceptable and uh
for the length of time it's been like
that as well
i i just don't accept that um
nothing can be done
thank you
right
okay look i
take the points you make um i agree that
it is unacceptable the way that it was
left
my understanding is that that's about to
be rectified very soon and not before
time and i think
you know an update to the council
into the future as to how that
because it wasn't just matera it was
gore as well
so how that program how that
particular situation was arrived at and
how it's been progressed to get it
sorted would be useful for councillors
to know because it's been brought to my
attention by
a number of residents and ratepayers
from both communities
um it's it hasn't hasn't been a a pretty
sight i'd have to say
counselor while you wish for i i agree
with you but
i don't agree that that gore isn't in
such a state as matera because at the
end of the day you cannot see gore
unless you go to the transfer station
where in matera you see it
on your left-hand side when you drive
through material you see it on your
right-hand side when you're coming out
of matera and it's there highly visible
in gore you can't see it because it's
been hidden by the trees on state
highway 1.
i'm acutely aware of the situation
councillor phillips
okay is there anything further in the
agenda councillor bulger
nikki
um item five
just to note um publicly that it's a
relief that the premixes finally left
the tara paper mill
and i see councillor phillips
acknowledged the hard work of the
community getting the issue resolved but
i also think we should acknowledge the
hard work of our chief executive to get
this resolved because this was
a very very onerous and difficult
process and he spent months
and months working with various parties
to actually get everyone together to get
agreement to finally get it moving so i
think a big ups to the matera community
for keeping the pressure on but i think
also we need to acknowledge the work of
the sea
thank you
well
yeah i absolutely agree um
nikki there's been a lot of people
put a lot of uh effort and time into
resolving the situation but
um
probably none as much as
steve perry and he does need to be
acknowledged
and and he will be acknowledged for that
but i guess we're um
we're just reviewing the minutes of the
meeting at this point in time
okay um
right counselor bulger you may
so both recommendations
okay do i have a second after that
council read thank you
uh
with
the points noted that have been
discussed
i'm going to put that motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
um we'll move on to item seven which is
uh minutes the gambling policy review
deliberative meeting which
occurred on the 7th of july
and we have a set of recommendations a
set of
comments
with a resolution at the end
is there any comments on
that set of minutes uh if there's not
with somebody like to me move that
they'll be be received
counselor phillips are you moving those
i think but i just like to acknowledge
the work of the council is doing an
excellent job on this and i like to move
it
okay do i have a secondary for that
counselor bulger
any comments with regard to minutes
let's not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
and that brings us on to the adoption of
the georgetown council class 4 gambling
and tab venue policies and we have a
memo attached from the chief executive
um do you want to
make some comments here steve
yeah thanks worship uh the policy really
reflects uh a continuing trend of this
council to try and minimise the social
impact of problem gambling
as the hearing committee
found out
each each round of review tends to bring
forward two schools of thought one is
the
we need to have the breaks on big time
in terms of reducing gambling
opportunities for class four gambling
and then there's the others that perhaps
have
an interest in
seeing
liberal liberalization of
gaming opportunities and the revenues
that can be produced there from and
wanting to see some relaxation
but the reality is that
with extremely strong existing use
rights that machines have what if they
were lawfully installed
in october 2001 there's limited
opportunity to see
reduction of machines and you've seen
over the years they've been
stubbornly stable i would
label it as so this policy really is a
continuation of sinking lid uh and
trying to
do the right thing by
some of those submitters that came up
with some pretty compelling arguments
why the council should not depart from
that syncing that
policy okay
thank you
um
so any discussion on the
on the desired
progress forward on this one
counselor grant
all right
seconder for that councillor grant
junior
um
is there any discussion open for
discussion
does not i'll put the motion always in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
uh brings us on to item nine southern
equestrian park trust replacement
trustee just a note on on this one
um
to list to this point from the
establishment of the
um
the all-weather
arena
there's been 10 trustees
and two of them come from from council
uh in
till this point in time uh it's been
um council grant and then council of
bulger
uh at the after the election and the
parks and recreation manager who
happened to be
ian soper
and i've talked to ian soper with regard
to this position and he gave me a clear
understanding of how that trust was was
formulated and
the council repres was to have two
representatives uh one was to be an
elected councillor and the other was to
be the parks and recreation manager
whoever that person might be at that
particular time
so
i
i'm pretty pleased that councillor
mcdonald's put his hand up and is
willing to to do this but i think it's
pretty important that we have that
formal connection uh from a council
staff perspective as well on this one
particularly relating to quite a bit of
the work that happens down there that
council's involved in and and also the
employee that that operates in
the amp
arena
so just a bit of clarity there
so i
is there any other comment from councils
or question with regard to that
um
could be the other trustee and that
would be uh an advantage seeing as
they're
aware of the budget
budget available for the
a p area so
there was a certain amount of comfort
around that additional
information
but it's up to the council how they uh
uh
progress or
handle that request
so um councillor heisted
you know i'd endorse your comments uh
your worship looking at the operation of
the joint management committee of the
amp society and council
and the relationship was set into that
it would make sense for the parks
reserve manager to
to be in both roles so
i'd support change and recommendation to
to reflect the appointment of the paris
reserve manager with all due respect to
councillor mcdowell for making himself
available
councilman
yeah i was only trying to help out by
filling the vacancy
that was created at the time
i appreciate that and thank you for your
willingness and and my understanding is
you are on the amp
so so you will be connected to the the
operation there something it was just
i was just filling a gap well
you didn't know how long you were gonna
have one person
okay so um councillor highset has
moved
an amendment to the well who moved a
recommendation that is different to the
one that's in the agenda do i have a
second for that councillor davis thank
you
um i'll put that motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
um
so
rural roads working party uh draft terms
of reference and this is another memo
that comes from the chief executive
uh there have been some
quite a lot of interest a little bit of
concern about um roads and how they are
managed and particularly in the in the
rural areas so i think there's some
potential in what we're putting together
here to just keep councillors a little
bit more connected uh to the operation
of of how that management goes but steve
do you want to make any comment here
yes your worship i've modeled modeled
modeled it along the lines of some of
the parameters are put for by the rarity
manager
at a previous meeting
and then endeavoured to
as best i as i could
to predict the type of comfort levels
you may have in regard to letting this
band of
keen elected members to get out there
and [ __ ] the roads and get stuck in
but so i have suggested that you want to
keep them within a fiscal envelope
within the council's overall roading
budget but the prioritisation
within that envelope is in my suggested
terms reference uh the
um preserve of the working party to to
do as it sees fit
but if i've got that wrong please feel
free it is only intended as a platform
or a starting point for debate
okay
thank you so this is open for discussion
um councilor mcdonough
we had a discussion at a meeting we had
the other day and there's one
and the objective we need to change the
wording there
it says to investigate road maintenance
standards in the rural roading network
and determine whether contractual
specifications are appropriate and
performance provider meets expectations
we need to change contractual
specifications that's the job of the
of the
of the
council staff we need just
overview some we had some word in that
though i can't remember what it was so i
didn't take a note of it can you
remember it
you just show your worship i think it
was in regard to those
removing that contractual specifications
and determine whether um i think it was
the requirements are met
i think that was if councillor garland
might
have a
contract a way out and just whether the
specifications are appropriate and
performance
i think i have a problem i think those
comments make sense do you want to make
a comment there steve just with regard
to that relationship between governance
and management
yeah thank you worship um
look it's it's one of those situations
where
um
my take was that some members of the
public were
concerned about
whether the council was getting value
for money in its railroading network
whether appropriate investment was being
made
and
the type of
specifications i use that would because
i can recall one submitter in particular
suggested that
the if
the current level of service either was
indicative of
a less than desirable performance
standard or whether the standard itself
hadn't been adequately specified
but more than happy to remove
contractual but what you'll find is that
when it comes to specifications
ultimately they are included in a
contract and that is what a contractor
will perform too
so
i think when you're talking standards um
ultimately the question will rise
what is the standard and the standard is
obviously in the contract
and if that stand is not
meeting expectations the question then
arises well can you change that and so
what is the funding impact
councilman
yes i think um just three worship to to
the ceo there i think probably the
concern was more around that we were
getting ourselves into the nuts and
bolts of um
actually negotiating operational matters
where we're looking at a more of a um a
strategic overview although within the
working group um
we have established there will be data
that will be given each month to the the
members of the working group to
establish that those specs are being met
so i think it was more around
to make sure we're not rolling our
sleeves too too much and um actually
filling the potholes ourselves with
gravel
although i think councillor cardone
might have might have been quite happy
with that we filled a few potholes but
um
yeah that's probably the uh
where we're heading to okay
okay so um just for my clarity
um
the change to this will be what will
that read like
peter standing actually wrote the words
down i didn't have a
pen with me that day
okay
looks like council mcfarland's got it at
his fingertips
okay
yeah
so i think probably just simply deleting
uh those two words contractual
specifications would suffice at this
point in time
do you you're moving that way accounts
yes your worship i was also wondering if
they should add
each of those three
rural councillors and a ward councillor
would be issued with a shovel and a
trailer
i was thinking this is just a shotgun
oh i'll move there you'll worship
messages
the main consumers uh contractuals so if
you just delete the contractual and left
specifications or you could put
standards in if that would be that
doesn't make sense standards are a kind
of like
less detailed more high level probably
more in sync with the governance role
yeah and that should happen so um the
two words contractual specifications
will be removed and replaced by
standards
and that's been moved by councillor
grant do i have a secretary for that
council make to now thank you
is there any further discussion on this
one councillor hosted
thank you russia i'm just looking at
authority to act where
the working party may reassign
priorities
within budget without approval of the
council
i just wonder if there should be some
regard to the short medium long term
implications of reassigning priorities
because we may change something now but
we we could cop that in in the long term
and i guess some of the cooperative
members will be quite motivated in terms
of where they'd like to see those
priorities put
so
i think there needs to be a catch all
behind that if we're going to
pass approval on to the working party um
some wording everyone having regard to
medium long-term implications of a
change in any priorities
yeah
okay so um
i think uh transit will have a pretty
big hand in that you won't better change
things too dramatically you'll better
move moving things around but transit
still is they sit they go through that
budget and they've picked and choose
what they fund and they will watch that
very closely
um i noticed most rural ratepayers have
had a significant lift in their uh rates
and there's been quite a bit of
discussion lately about that and i asked
lorraine about that and um a lot of that
is due to the right lift and the funding
for unsealed roads in air district
and that came through on peter's report
the other day yeah
i understand that and get that but this
is the council's role and this is being
handed over so yes it might it may not
be significant but so
steve you just made a suggestion in my
year then
you should worship you could have
the so for the avoidance of doubt the
working party may reassign priorities
with the within the existing
budget
having regard for long any long-term
impacts
without the approval of counsel
it sounds fine councillors comfortable
with that
did you get that susan
yeah okay thank you
finances and where they are directed
between rural and urban so and that came
down to a discussion around
reprioritizing things so
the the opportunity was not to
change um
the magnitude of funding in the ltp and
shift
you know shift
from an urban span to a rural span it
was just to re-prioritize
within
uh the rural roading framework so that
was appreciated by the committee but you
know that's a little bit more clarity
around that won't but we were aware of
that
okay so with those two um
changes
and the the moves of the original motion
you're comfortable with that
okay
right i'm going to put that emotional
eyes in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
all right brings us on to item 11 and a
combined submission from a number of
councils on the natural and built
environments built
a significant piece of legislation
and
we've had a
glimpse into what it looks like but
haven't really got a whole lot of
understanding as to what the
implications of this might be but my
my take on it from what i know is that
it's likely to have significant effect
on
not only councils but also on to the
wider populace as a whole and will
change the way that we we do things
but
thank you for the chief to the chief
executive for the
um
for the memo and the submission do you
want to make any comment to that steve
you just briefly worship and as i
alluded to in the um cavern report
three waters at the moment is the um
i guess the
star child in terms of attention and
concern within the local government
sector
yet when you stand back and look at it
clinically this particular
change
is far wide reaching
and
while i'm involved in a reference group
of chief executives
working with
ministry for the environment and dia on
assisting with
some feedback on provisions of the new
regime
it's still
an incredibly large and complex
piece of work
and how it will all shake down
particularly it sounds so ideal to have
66 plans
reduced down to 14 but we look at it and
with the same not so much the southern
region but next door in otago and one
plan for that entire region and given
the
um
incredibly contrasting
districts that contain that are
contained within that region
and one committee that will be charged
with putting that plan together
that's an incredibly imposing
piece of work and then there's obviously
the issues around how do local people
get input into a constructing their plan
and being having a plan that reflects
local preferences
and then the impact on
both resource users and the regulatory
body which is currently the district
council for example
how that interface works so
there's enormous amount of work to to to
come i think the government
has done
a good job in having this very novel
approach of having a exposed draft but
the in reality
as worship said when you're only getting
about
15 to 20 percent of best nibble at a
a wider picture
it's very hard to
to comment in some definition and you
you do tend to hit your bets it's a bit
like
we've been given 20 of a jigsaw puzzle
and saying give us the whole picture uh
tell us what you think it is
so it's a bit like that it's not no
one's fault but the full
monty won't be produced until the early
22
and that it promises i think to be a
pretty robust select committee process
where
people can actually see the whole
picture unfold and figure out the
enormity of the changes and whether
they're comfortable with it
because at the moment there's still
even within what's exposed to us
the language is
a lot of us can see that it's not as
definitive as we would like and it could
possibly
set up a platform for further litigious
argument to find what is supposed to
what is the the true intent meaning of
this new legislation given that the rma
was subjected to a 30-year brutal
assault in the same
way to try and figure out what it all
means
okay so open for discussion
and endorsement of the recommendation or
operation
so um
councilor dixon
um thank you worship
as uh as being involved in the some of
the assessment of the changes in 1991
it's it's really quite concerning to see
the same issues arriving in terms of
prescriptiveness and the intent
of the rma now
and i'm also concerned about the impact
of the rma the proposed rma on the rate
pays because um we're well into our
review of the district plan and what
that what that means for us is that
going to be an extra cost and will have
to be changes
just just on that point do you want to
make it a comment there steve yeah that
was a comment a point counselor that was
discussed at one of our early meetings
with the chief ezekiel reference group
because uh some councils are like like
gore are in the midst of a review
uh the
feeling
at that time and i've not been advised
anything differently
is that it's good for a council to get
its ducks in a row get its thinking
established about what it wants to see
in its in its district
with a thought that
uh but to perhaps pause before you
notify
so that you can see what the legislative
landscape is going to be like with the
new um
legislation coming to replace the
resource management act
and then with the view to possibly
have the thinking in a draft document to
be able to be incorporated into a new
regional plan
so the message that i received was you
shouldn't stop
until you get to a point where you might
be starting to notify and go through the
the quite prescriptive procedures within
the resource management act regarding
district plan review and that's where
you might want to pause and then feed
into
whatever
the new legislation looks like for the
new um
natural and built environment act
okay
good point
um okay councillors any any further
comments or question with regard to this
piece of legislation that we're working
our way through council macphail
it's not it's more just a three worship
just a statement in regard to i think
the ceo's
commentary there is um
is well laid out and when we look at
the frustrations that failed by officers
developing a submission i think that
with the government at the moment and
obviously the small percentage of
information that we are getting in
regard to some of these large
scale
strategic
plans and directions has become quite a
common theme
that we have to have these
exposure drafts
it's almost
another
process that's becoming
um commonplace
that here here's what's coming and uh
we'll give you a small amount of
information but we want you to be
prepared to make some very large
decisions or
submissions on it so
interesting times we live in
okay
if there's nothing else would somebody
like to move the recommendation
move councillor davis do i have a
signature for that council dixon thank
you
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye against the motion is
carried
right that brings us to the end of the
open session of the agenda
oh apart from the urgent general
business that was
uh notified
earlier in the meeting
um and i haven't got the copy right in
front of me
okay
so we have a an item that has come from
the um
come from the communication
communications
manager with regard to community awards
review
and some potential changes that
could possibly happen there so sony do
you want to talk us through this and
then we'll open it for discussion
yes thank you worship um before i start
though i can just take this opportunity
to introduce to council as our new event
coordinator jessica swann who's sitting
here
to my right um she's in week two of the
job so it's good to have her on board
um i just want to say that the report's
very self-explanatory
um obviously the community awards has
become a signature event for the council
and um we saw what an incredible effort
went into last year um and what an
amazing success it was
to sustain that though does take a lot
of resources both in terms of people
resources and and financially
so um you know i think the the option
that we felt in discussion was by making
it violent then makes it um
it retains that prestige and and that
that expectancy so i'm happy to take any
questions and of course the community
strategy manager here um and who was
also involved in it um she's happy to
answer your questions as well
so and before we go on to questions do
you want to make any comment on this one
the only comment i really make is that
i think by
going every second year with this event
you're a small community
and it's really important to be able to
keep the number of nominations to keep
the standard and the prestige of this
event so that has been
that has happened in other communities
um
and we have
you know tabled in the past that
the events area has been quite stretched
so this is a way of also balancing out
some of the resourcing issues
we need to bring this now to you because
of the timing of this event
yeah okay
thank you and
thank you for the report thank you for
the thinking that's going on behind the
report
i'm acutely aware of how important the
community awards are
to this community and certainly from a
council perspective
uh it's been an absolute pleasure to be
involved all these years and to to see
the
some of the stellar performers that we
have in our community getting the
recognition that they deserve
however i do acknowledge some of the
challenges around
getting numbers of nominees on a regular
basis on a 12 monthly cycle so i think
it's it's good that we pause and just
take a um
take a breath to consider uh are there
other ways of doing this
we have
you know
when when this was begun
it really was probably the
certainly the largest and and one of the
few community events that council was
involved in we have a number of events
um going now and
and i think putting the energy that we
need to into those events um
uh does require quite a lot of resource
so
it's not a an issue from a council
perspective whether we have it or don't
i know that but
i think it's something we do need to
consider just alongside some of these
other events that are
starting to
to gain gain traction but certainly from
my perspective i have witnessed the
challenge in getting nominations
for various sections
and i think it's worthwhile giving it
some serious thought at this stage so
open for discussion council read
thank you worship
um thank you both anne and sonia for the
work that you put into the report
i'm quite happy
personally to think that we went to a
bi-annual event simply because it does
keep that standard high
the only question i would have
just thinking about some of our young
people who
achieve over that i'm assuming that
their achievements would be over two
years as opposed to one
because a lot of the young ones move on
to tertiary education and leave the
district but it would be nice to think
that
that time frame would cover them i
assume it does
yes most certainly there would be a sec
period for for eligibility and it would
cover that two-year period thank you
yeah
kelsey grant and councilman fowle so you
worship so in
in
carrying on from councillor reed's
question
because
when when it's advertised the following
year uh there will be people that
in your mind drop off the radar from the
previous year and all of a sudden
at some times sometimes tend to
be those people that are in your
thoughts for that you know the last six
months or whatever but
so in saying that is there a way that we
could um
or you could um
do these awards so that you can nominate
them from now until well obviously the
nomination's open now but um
it's not for another
what's that 14 months or 15 months from
now so the people that have
are eligible you know what i'm saying
eligible now they might drop off the
radar so if it's sort of something that
you can
put the nominations out there for this
year and then next year then you combine
the two
so
some awards that go like every second
year they will open the nomination not
just a few months before it's actually
more about when you close it
so absolutely you could open it earlier
and then you just choose when you did
your publicity around it because like
you say um councillor grant you might
have top of mind somebody you want to
put in and you want to do it now while
you're thinking about it so absolutely i
think we can work within that so the
likes of you could have the
you run the awards every two years but
uh you have a
2021 award and a 202 award but it's run
every two years
you'd probably still have one award but
you would have it open for a longer
period
yeah that's where you'll go okay
okay um
good questions council macphail
um just through worship supportive of
the bi-annual
change there
the only thing i'd be sort of
wondering whether uh in the stand down
period through the year there whether we
review some of those categories and see
whether we're still
um relevance and also that we're
reflecting the um diversity the way that
our our um the face of our community is
changing so
just i'm not sure what
which ones but maybe it would be a good
time to do that and look at um when it's
two years now there might be another
category or some sort of
relevant category look i agree with
the question you ask and and i believe
that we should be we should be doing it
on a regular basis and and we have from
time to time
changed award as time has gone on but i
think that we are a community that is
changing quite quickly um and we our
makeup is quite different our focus on
areas of activity and achievement is
quite different to what it was five
years ago even uh so we need to be able
to reflect that so sonia do you want to
make any comment i was just about to say
pretty much what you said actually yeah
completely and awesome that we will be
um it gives us an opportunity to have a
real critical and strategic review of
the whole event which is which is really
good
okay other questions or
comments
i
okay then would somebody like to move
the recommendation move councillor reed
diver senator counselor make to now
thank you
so the report is moved and
seconded
if there's no further comment i'm going
to put that all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors and um thank you for um
everyone that's played a part in
uh putting this review together
and
and will play a part in uh providing us
with
the first
new formatted uh community awards in
probably
13 or 14 months time from now no
pressure yes
but
it is it is a benchmark for this
district what has occurred right from
the very beginning when i think from
memory i guess
the very first guest we had was eric
rush
and he was a hit from day one and in
every one since then has bought some new
dynamic uh to the discussion and uh
and the presentation that they have on
the on the night and i know of nobody
that hasn't appreciated what they've
heard and what they've been part of so i
look forward to what the new event will
look like
and wish everyone the best for what
what is going to eventuate
okay um
is there any there's no other urgent
general business that i'm aware of so if
there's not i'm going to call an end to
the open session of the council meeting
and move the council
exclude the public from the